so one of the things I've learned as
I've been jumping in Android is about
all of the features that you can really
take advantage of and one of those is
stateful drawables now I've come from a
swing background in Java and so I'm used
to okay let's say I have a button on the
screen and when the user clicks on that
button or maybe they mouse over it I
want that icon to change to maybe an
inverted icon I so the way I'd write
that in swing is you'd write an
onclicklistener or a non mouse over a
mouse move listener to watch for those
actions and then swap out the image but
with Android you don't have to write
those with stateful drawables you can
have a single image that changes the
image that changes what it is based on
the state so I don't have to write that
code as the user moves over something or
when they touch something or as they
check an item that I that image
automatically changes for me a second
thing I've really found valuable is the
hierarchy viewer I found myself a lot of
times as I'm trying to lay out a view
and really see how things work on the
screen that it doesn't look the way I
want it to something's not working out
and so many times instead of just
tweaking little changes one at a time to
see you know how can i fix this how can
I make this layout work the way I want
it to I can use the higher key viewer to
really drill down and see how things are
being laid out on the device where the
boundaries of the objects are so that I
can clearly see where things are being
laid out and how I could reorganize to
solve the problem and fix the view to
make it the way I want it